hi i'm miles
aka the pool guy and i'm going to show
you how i professionally clean the
bottom of a pool
today i'm going to show you a few
different pools and how i clean the
bottom of the pool
grandma's pool definitely was the most
challenging
um the sludge on the bottom it was like
six inches of sludge like
across the whole pool it looked very
abandoned because
obviously it'd been left 15 years
so that was like when i first got into
the pool obviously there was a lot of
the water had been drained down quite a
lot there but as i stepped in it was
really soft branches may have fell off
of like the
the bushes that are around the pool um
and then just sort of like they could
have started growing like bigger as well
while they were in the court as well so
so we had to shovel it into sort of
buckets and then when someone would put
it in a wheelbarrow and then
take it down to the heap at the end of
the garden and it just created like a
massive pile of just sludge
i'd say there was probably like a ton or
maybe two tons of sludge
so yeah get like draining that down and
uh
like scooping all the floods out of that
one and just the time it took
um yeah that was definitely the hardest
one but we got there in the end
[Music]
oh my god so recently i've been to a job
um
and the pool has been left for like
eight years but the water weirdly was
like clear
but the algae in there was really like
blanket-like
and there was loads of it and you could
see like a move around you can see it
looked like really weird like an
underwater sort of like
forest of like algae it was like really
bad
um and that ball definitely had to be um
drain down okay so when i first go to a
pool
and i see that it's green what i'll do
first is get
um a pool brush out and i'll brush the
whole pool
all the surfaces disturbing all the
algae off the surface
normally algae will just like break up
but you put chemicals in and you brush
the
the pool um and it will just break up
into like really small particles and
then you can just like hoover it
but like this type of algae was just
like really like
stringy and just like solid
together um yeah it was a weird one
um and then again there's like sludge on
the floor was sort of just like brushing
the sludge
to like a pile and then like scooping
out
[Music]
that pool had been left and just sort of
like gone a couple of days without
chlorine
and because it was sort of like indoor
it had like sort of like in a greenhouse
type so it got like really hot in there
when the sun comes out and just the
algae just attached itself to the tiles
like
so badly it looked like it had been left
for like years
people thought they were actually green
tiles on the steps
and it was really tough on the tiles it
needed something quite aggressive to
sort of get it off and then what i got
was just like some
hydrochloric acid and mixed it with
water
and uh sprayed it over the tiles and it
just started reacting with the
um the algae um bubbling up
and then i started brushing it in to
disturb it all off the surface
then i got the the hose and started
watering it down and it all cleaned
cleaned off come up
and blue and then rinsed it down and
that literally took like
15 minutes
the woman who earned the pool she didn't
she only called us to come and open the
pool
in like august had like the whole summer
just sitting there doing nothing
so like we took the the cover off and
there was like mosquito larvae in the
pool and there was mosquitoes
like flying everywhere literally so bad
i had to like run away from the pool
and she actually didn't want
this pool emptied she just wanted to try
and get it around with like chemicals
get some chemicals out shop and chlorine
granules we used on this one
so like when i shock a pool that
basically kills off
all the algae and all the contaminants
in the ball basically what it does is
combine all the small particles
and what it relies on is like no
movement in the water
so it's combining all the particles and
then they become like heavy and then
they just sink to the bottom
yeah after a few days come back and it
was like uh the water was crystal clear
just all the debris and i think it was
just on the bottom and i came in and i
just hovered it up and it was just
crystal clear
ready to go sort of thing
[Music]
so if you've got an outdoor pool you're
going to want to maintain it like
once a week at least no so i get a lot
of people do say to me why don't you
drain the pool
before winter but what it is is you
gotta
take into consideration like the
structure of the pool so if you have no
water in there
if there's water in the ground
surrounding the pool it can
pressurize the walls and then cause
damage
but you have to keep water in the pool
um what you do have to do
is check your pool at least like once a
month and add the correct chemicals
and then when you come to open in summer
it's going to be nice and clear still
you